I came to Stanford because I was writing
the business column for The Wall Street
Journal and I thought if I was going to
write that column i oughtta have a
deeper richer understanding of business
the timing was right it was a summer
program six weeks was about right for my
schedule most of us spend our lives in
these silos and you come here and you
have these really great professors and
you have these classmates who are from
every industry and from every part of
the world and you start hearing about
their experiences and the things they're
going through and it enables you to look
at your business in a very different way
so it was it was eye-opening I ended up
spending a lot of my time thinking about
what canoes papers due in general and
what can the Wall Street Journal do
specifically to get over the challenges
that it currently faced my experience at
SCP totally changed my career path I
don't write the column anymore I spent
all my time working on innovation on the
digital platform and we've been able to
do exactly what I thought about during
that time at Stanford when I look at
what I learned and what I thought about
and how it is affected not only my
career but how it's affected the fate of
the wall street journal in Dow Jones III
think there's no argument that it was
well worth it many times over
you